have you ever heard of the time when
they tried to redefine pi
when it was to redefine pi so that it
was 3.2
i'm about to ask yes you are this is
absolutely insane it's a true story as
well and it's absolutely crazy so this
happened
well i don't think that long ago it was
and there was a guy called edwin goodwin
this amateur mathematician who thought
he had solved one of the unsolved
problems of mathematics
a problem that goes way back to ancient
greece it was called squaring the circle
the problem is can you find a square
that has the same area as a circle so
this problem goes way way back
and it's a favorite problem for amateur
mathematicians and this guy thought he
had solved the problem but implicitly in
his proof
he had assumed that pi was exactly 3.2
now he was so pleased with his proof
he just he wanted to copyright the proof
itself so that anyone using the proof
from that point on would have to pay him
royalties but
he decided that the great state of
indiana
which is where he's where he was from
that the educational establishments of
indiana could use it for free
how kind of him and so what he did was
he had a bill made up
and he tried to pass it into law
that
would recognize the mathematical truth
that he had discovered
but it would allow indiana to use it for
free so i think he had a friend someone
he knew who was part of the house of
representatives in indiana and they
made up this bill
saying that
the great mathematical truth of square
in the circle now this bill
went through committees uh went through
the education committee in the house of
representatives and they obviously
didn't know what they were doing because
they passed the bill and the the
representatives
actually passed it unanimously 67 to
zero they passed it now this is the
weird bit
on the same day that they were passing
the bill there was a mathematician in
the building
he was there for a completely different
reason
right he was a guy called professor
waldo but he decided to sit in on what
they were discussing because it was
about maths he was interested
and he couldn't believe what he was
hearing
they invited him to meet edwin goodwin
oh do you want to meet edwin we're very
proud of him he said no i meet enough
crazy people as it is thank you very
much
so
this mathematical professor
then decided to coach the senate the
next thing that happens is the bill
goes from the house of representatives
to the senate
so this professor
coached the senate senators
so that they knew what they were doing
by this time
the newspapers had heard of it they were
mocking what was going on so when it
reached the senate
they threw it out right they threw it
out not before having a bit of fun with
it they had about half an hour of maths
puns
and making jokes about it
then they threw it out but seriously
there are there are solutions to square
solutions to square in the circle where
you take really good approximations to
pi
uh
more serious mathematicians for example
ramanujan who was an indian
mathematician and a brilliant one at
that
he had a solution to this as well so
ramanujan came up with an approximation
uh which means that he if you made a
circle with an area of 140 000 square
miles
then you could have a square with the
same area and the sides of the square
would be off
just by an inch so edwin goodwin had
done this in 1897 and the you can see
the documents it's absolutely true this
story you can you can look at the
documents yourself you can read it
and it's a strange thing to happen as
well because the problem he was trying
to solve squaring the circle was proved
to be impossible
15 years earlier in
1882 so i think we should have a video
about
squaring the circle and what it means
should we do that shall we do that we'll
film that okay we're about to film it
now tune in tune in soon and we'll show
you about squaring the circle
let's have a look at what you can do
with rules and compasses
you can add numbers look
here's a line and it has length a
then i add another line of length b
and the whole thing
is a plus b